hello chess fans
how are you guys doing it's a pleasure
for me to be here in another
lecture in this case games of
the week my name is pepe cuenca spanish
grandmaster
and as you guys know norway chess
is taking place right now in norway
gathering some of the best chess players
in the world including the world
champion magnus carlsen
the wall number two fabiano caruana
and wells like ariana tari
alireza firuza and
lebon aronian six players they are
playing round robin to
ten rounds and bring you one of the most
exciting games one of the most
instructive games
played by the world champion magnus
carlsen so maybe
i'm gonna put the names on the bar as
well so you guys can see the evaluation
in every position so let me just uh well
let's
let's do it like this okay magnus
carlsen had white pieces and arie and
charity had the black pieces
so uh let's start analyzing what
happened in that game so magnus carlsen
played e4 and arientari replied with e5
so hello to hyverdan
i'll be asking you guys some questions
and uh of course
just any suggestion that you wanna uh
suggest
just uh let me know in the youtube chat
i'll be paying attention to that as well
so magnus carlsen where for knight three
ari antar
knight c6 by the way aryan is a super
talented player from norway as well
i i believe is uh he is the number two
of norway
he's a very good guy we shared him in
the swedish league like a couple of
years ago
and he is a very good guy
okay so knight c6
and bishop b5 this one is real lopez
other options for white here you can go
for the scotch with d4
you can go for the italian yoko piano
with bishop c4
also for the four knights variation
after knight c3 knight f6
but the main line is bishop b5 the
spanish real opus
now ariane goes for the main spanish
with a6
and knight f6 of course
leads to the berlin defense one of the
most
solid approaches for black against the
relop is it became very famous
this opening uh when kramnik started to
use it
right and since then it's been one of
the main weapons
from every top player right from every
top gun
in the chess world so a6 now may move
bishop a4
from magnus carlsen you can also go for
the exchange of finance
spanish sorry after bishop takes c6 it
takes
c6 but this is another story and bishop
a4 from magnus carlsen
knight to f6 and sure castle
here the main move is bishop e7 as
aryantari played you can also go for
knight takes e4 and after d4
b5 b bishop b3
d5 t takes e5 bishop b6 there is a lot
of
theory regarding this line as well
you can also go for b5 followed by
bishop c5
intend to go for the archangel
variations for example peter schwidler
is one of the experts in this line
everything's fine right
regarding audio video guys just let me
know if there is some trouble
i'll try to fix it but i guess
everything's fine okay so bishop e7
main line and here magnus calzon decides
to go for d3
d3 just protecting the pawn on e4 the
other main option
is to go rookie one we have to say that
ari antary was playing the
martial gambit in this tournament before
for example he played against lemon
ironian
fantastic game where finally the
armenian
won how do you enter in the marshall
gambit well with b5
bishop b3 shark castle and c3
black plays d5 e takes d5
knight takes d5 knight takes e5 give me
that
give me that and c6 and black has
sacrificed upon but in return has a lot
of compensation
why because all white pieces are
completely stacked
on the queen side and now black is going
to play bishop g6
in the next move and look at these
bishops
they are so strong pointing to white
skin and also the queen can join the
party
by a h4 and there is so much
compensation
in this line of course this is uh this
has been
discussed in many uh top gains between
top players right and there's a lot of
heavy theory
behind that okay
so instead magnus calzone goes for d3
one of the most experts in this line is
also peter spidler eight times russian
champion right
okay so d3 and b5 from ariane tari
bishop b3 and d6
what's the idea behind d6 you guys know
what is black threatening in this
position
it's a positional threat of course black
is not gonna threaten
checkmate or something like one move in
two moves
but black is threatening something for
example if i play h3
what would you play here with the black
pieces
would you go for sure castle will you go
for bishop e6
maybe d5 no would you go for a5
no bishop g4 no
bishop g4 is not a threat actually after
d6 bishop
g4 is natural move but there is a
positional threat
there is a positional threat now the
pawn on e5
is well protected yeah mithra my guy
you're always there that's right knight
a5
is the positional threat because black
will get the bishop
and believe me in the elite chess the
bishop player is quite important
so here that's why after d6
white has to do something about the
bishop on b3
we have to say that before g6
black can't go for knight a5 because the
pawn on e5
is just hanging so that's why we say
that d6 is threatening knight a5
so you see there's always some reasons
behind the
opening theory so here white can
uh give some pressure to this bishop by
playing c3
aiming to go to c2 in case of knight a5
in the game magnus carson went for a4
which also
helps uh with that purpose and the move
a3
is also very natural we have to say that
in the real lopez in many cases you want
to develop the pieces with
c3 knight g2 rookie one knight f1
knight g3 this knight on g3 is well
placed because it not only
supports the e e4 pawn because in many
cases you want to
push the center with d4 and e4 has to be
protected but also from g3
in so many cases you want to jump to f5
and then start creating some
troubles on black skin sorry for so many
arrows guys but
but also after the move a3 black can try
to play in different style
in many cases sorry white white is
aiming to
use this d5 square with the move knight
c3 and then bishop g5 also knight d5
but okay in this game magnus galson
decides to go
for a4 with an immediate threat of
taking on b5
different ways for black to deal with
this you can go rook b8
you can play b4 which weakens a little
bit
the light squares right pepe
you have played a match against uh
magnus isn't he too consistent
how playing him is different than other
guys of course he just crushed me
you know we played in the banta blitz
cap like uh
i think it was a year ago in december i
believe
and then he crashed me eight eight and a
half bears was half you know
so i was so happy when i managed to get
a draw against him
and yeah i mean he's a beast yeah and
uh even in the in the semi-finals he
played zugitov which is almost a 2700 he
beat him
nine zeros and the other day he beat
anishgiri in the banter series five and
a half versus
one and a half but of course to me was
an extremely great experience to
to play against the world champion what
else can i ask for right of course i
will
i would love to to lose against him
every day right it's a it's it was a
really nice opportunity
and uh since uh all these online
platforms
exist i have i have had the opportunity
to face
all these top guns in different events
and it's just
very interesting and very happy that i
managed to to participate against them
for example like i think was like one
month ago or two months ago
i had the opportunity to play a match
against peter schwidler
and it was a lot of fun he beat me four
and a half versus two and a half but i
managed to
to to get a win and to make three draws
so
i mean just the opportunity that you
learn so much by by facing these guys
yeah
okay so a4 and uh arientari
replies with bishop g7 just protecting
this rook on a8
and magnus goes for c3 really natural
move
as i told you many cases the bishop goes
to c2
and you're also aiming to go d4
at some point right so ariane goes for
knight
a5 and the first move that surprised me
a little bit in
in this game was bishop a2 from magnus
carlsen i think we were all expecting
bishop c2
because it looked like you played c3
just to give this square for the bishop
and also you protect a4
so bishop a4 the first question that
comes to our mind is
black can take this guy on a4 looks like
that
but i'm going to show you some positions
where
black white is going to sacrifice an
exchange on a4 for example
arientari went for c5 one of the main
purposes after knight a5
is just to occupy the center with the
move c5 and then
once this knight has made uh the job
by kicking this bishop from b3 and also
now in c5 this knight will come back to
c6
just controlling more important squares
right
so c5 from aryan terry and
magnus kalsan went for bishop g5
once that black has played c5 d5
becomes awake square right so in many
positions we want to
put a piece right there for example an
item d2 then can join
f1 and then goes to e3 where you control
d5 what i mean this square is very tasty
for white so
magnus carlsen were for bishop g5
and shark castle by arianthari
magnus carlsen b to d2 and when i was
doing commentary on this game
i thought why not to take this pawn on
a4 i mean magnus is giving him
so many chances to take this guy on a4
and
it was hard to me to understand why not
to take it and now
when i was analyzing this game for you
guys i took my chessboard i started
thinking like for
half an hour and i found some nice ideas
i thought this was very reasonable for
black because because you cannot uh
you don't only take a a free pawn but
also you open the b
file for the rook you're gonna put some
pressure on b2
and also the not that the b3 square is
tasty for the knight in the future
but here they're interesting options for
white
for example one of them is just taking
on f6
bishop takes f6 bishop d5 rook b8
and rook takes a4 and this is extremely
interesting for for for white let's say
bishop a4
queen a4 and knight b7 we just grab this
pawn on a6
and white has a bishop and a pawn for
the rook but
look at this bishop this bishop is like
batman yeah and superman all together
it controls everything it puts pressure
on f7 and the knight is basically
it's just a terrible knight on b7 right
it hasn't got squares
so this position the engine says is
around equal
but i believe that in practice is even
easier for white to play
because you got ideas with knight c4
maybe rook a1
g3 you can prove the position of your
kin step by step king g2
and i don't see a clear plan for black
to play here
right so maybe
magnus had prepared something like this
i don't know
we would never know because ari and
tarry he didn't took on
he didn't take sorry on a4 and he just
played rook b8
now he's showing his intentions now he
wants to take on a4 because
he puts pressure on b2 and magnus says
you know what you had your chance
but now i'm gonna take on b5 and then
you're not gonna take that pawn on a4
anymore so a takes b5
and now i want to ask you what would you
play here with the white pieces just
give me some plans
so would you play bishop d5
maybe b4 maybe h3 rookie one
just tell me some ideas behind this
position that you have in your mind
this is a position which is very
flexible most of relopez
are so interesting and most of trainers
recommend the kids to
to to start playing the real opus
because all the pieces are in the
chessboard there are many ideas
many strategical plans many tactical
shots
it's so rich the position is so flexible
that uh that it's it's it's great to
learn chess
so b4 c3 i have a lot of suggestions
from you guys
that's amazing so b4 before the problem
with b4
i believe is that black can take on c b4
and knight c6
and now we have some troubles here and
b4 right this one is going to be weak so
i really don't like this b4 idea h3
a3 of course this is a natural move as
well
but nobody says the move that magnus
carlsen played
so what do what do we want to do with
this knight on d2
you want to put this knight on b3 or
maybe in some other square
it's a very natural plan in the real
opposite we always do
something with this knight on d2
so any ideas
yeah that's right mithra my guy
rook e1 awesome this is the move that
magnus carlsen played
now we want to regroup this knight from
f1 and then why not
to bring it to e3 full control of these
two important squares
d5 and f5 and also with the rook on e1
at some point
um you want to push with d4 and e4 will
be overprotected
and now what do you think about uh
okay arientari went for b4 but what do
you think about this bishop e6
because i have different feelings for
this move
you like bishop e6 it's clear that the
best piece in the real lopez in many
yoko piano positions in many italians is
the bishop on a2
it's a fantastic bishop yeah this bishop
goes to the disco it's able to dance
with everybody you know
knows every song is the king of the
dance floor this bishop on a2
meanwhile this bishop when he said on e7
is a little bit shy you know what
he doesn't dance you know he's just in
the bar just drinking something you know
but this bishop on e2 is just a rock
star
so what do you think about this bishop
e6 you like it
or not just to trade this strong bishop
from a2 of course it has some drawbacks
for black
and i'm trying to explain you what are
the drawbacks for black
also some advantages so
yeah sumitran suggests some interesting
idea of course
the critical option here for white is
just to take on e6
and there are different uh pros and cons
after these positions so the pros
for for white let's say the cons for
black
are that for example now your structure
is completely ruined right
i mean not completely ruined but you
have you got double pawns
on the e file what are the pros well you
now have full control
on these two important squares d5 was
weak before
and now it's not weak and f5 same
situation
and also you have opened this file for
the rook so you have a semi file open
uh sorry op yeah open
semi file semi open file i don't know
what i'm talking about anymore
semi-open file the f5 and also you got
some routes for the queen
to attack white skin
but the problem is that as the
metronome was suggested d4 comes
with some troubles for black in this
position right so if white manages to
play
d4 black will suffer a little bit and
also there is another cute move here in
this position which is queen b1
queen b1 is threatening to go queen a2
in this position with a double attack on
the a5 knight and on the e6
pawn you cannot go queen b7 and if you
remove the knight let's say
knight c6 then moves like rook a6 queen
a2
rook a1 white has also the possibility
to create some pressure
on the queen side on the a5
so it's always a move to consider but in
this case i believe
white is a little bit better there are
other positions in the yoko piano where
i even prefer black after this trade of
bishops
because the attack against white skin is
so obvious
with the knight on h5 then
a queen to e8 and queen to g6
knight h5 knight f4 but in this position
i see i think the attack is just
very very ins it's not sufficient
against
white skin right okay so after this
uh philosophical discussion let's move
on
and ari antary went for b4 this weakens
a little bit the dark squares
and now magnus carlsen plays knight c4
knight takes e4 bishop takes c4
b take c4 b take c4
and here ari and tari went for queen
c7 i think the other option was to go
98 just trying to drag this uh dark
square bishops bishop e7
queen e7 i think white is a little bit
better after the move rook
a7 so this is why i think uh
uh aryan titan did go for a 98.
so let's move on and queen c7 and magnus
carlsen
queen c2 and arie antary went for bishop
b5 what do you think about this move
this is another very important moment in
the game
so guys tomorrow morning before going to
compete in the swedish league i'm gonna
play
paddle you play paddle in your countries
you know what paddle is it's not paddle
surf
some sort of tennis i think it's only
played in few countries
i think it was born in mexico and then
it was very very
uh trendy in spain argentina but in
sweden they have a lot of cards
now
it's like some sort of tennis with walls
it's not squash
it's not badminton or table tennis it's
called paddle
here bishop f6 bishop f6 has
trouble has a problem what is the
problem with bishop f6
you tell me aryan
you tell me what's the problem behind
bishop f6
black is not going to take on f6 but
instead
black is going to take on c4 and now you
take on e7
there's bishop b3 and queen e7
okay it's true that you can take on d6
so maybe bishop f6 is also interesting
that's right yeah bishop f6 is
interesting
but the point is that now
white is going to take on b5 and then
take on f6
as magnus carlsen did in the game
and we reached this position where we
have a fantastic knight and this bishop
is just
not so good because you know it's
blocked by his own pawns and we have so
many
weaknesses on the light squares and
magnus carson from this point plays a
fantastic game
uh it starts it starts torturing
his opponent and we're going to see how
the game uh finishes
but it's just it was just an amazing
technique from magnus carlsen
because here bishop takes b5 bishop
takes v5 if i play knight d2
i'm gonna give you a try with the black
pieces
of course now i want to take on f6 but
there is some nice move for black here
important moment for aryan terry this
would have been
yeah ariane you are so strong man what
did you eat today
some broccoli knife d5 that's right
so now black at least manages to play a
position
where it's a little bit worse but at
least it's night vs night it's not
bad bishop versus versus knight because
this knight could become strong at some
point
pizza for lunch that's nice okay
instead magnus didn't give ariana tardy
this option and then he goes for bishop
f6
you guys see there is always a reason
behind every move
it's not just by it's not randomly
played yet
so bishop f6 bishop f6 and
knight d2 okay
so what would be your plan
with the black pieces in this position
would you try to go for g5
would you try to go for f5 at some point
or would you just sit and wait
and try to play solid in this position
beep
i would eliminate the b file rook
matan is saying
i'm talking about the black pieces
yeah so you are suggesting uh something
for why yeah you want to
exchange a pair of rooks that's a nice
idea
so in general these positions are a
torture for black because even though if
black manages to exchange
everything i mean the two rooks and the
and the queen
this and games are very tough to play
for black because
white has always some nice routes for
the kin on the light squares and d6 so
is always going to be
a weakness for the rest of the game aim
for d5
double the rooks okay everything you say
makes sense you want to double the rooks
you want to play d5
you want to play g6 bishop g7 and f5
all of that makes sense let's start by
saying that doubling the rooks
you don't achieve anything because with
an iron c4 you're never going to make it
to b2
right and aiming for g5 could be an
option so you can dream
of giving this bishop some open diagonal
in the future
so that's great guys so ari and zari
decide to go for queen c6
aiming to go for d5 maybe in some
position
it's not even easy for example if i play
g3 play now d5
or not
and we have uh i mean we don't need to
say that of course
black would love to trade this bishop
for this night but it's never gonna be
easy
never gonna be easy
so is d5 possible in this position not
yet right because there is a fork
so it's not even easy to play for d5
here because after d5
you just take this pawn on d5 queen
takes d5
and ba-boom c4 and white wins
immediately
okay so magnus carlsen went for another
plan
he just played queen a4 which also stops
d5 but in this type of positions you can
basically play whatever you want with
the white pieces you don't have
any anything to fear about i mean
you can play probably g3 knight c4 king
g2
and then you can decide whether you want
to put some pressure on the a
file you wanna i mean you should decide
whether if you want to trade
just one rook or the queens but
you have no risks in this position
so rook f2 b8 from ariana tari
and knight c4 from magnus carlsen
and here ariane plays bishop e7
so basically now black gave up on this
plan with f5
right right it's g3 from magnus carlsen
would you play a3 or g3
where do you want to place your kin on
h2 or g2
i think g2 is better because i like the
the setup with the pawns on h2 g3 and f2
because the king on g2 is fantastically
placed and then
at some point you could think of going
f4 as well right
uh even h4h5 to increase the pressure
yeah i also prefer the way magnus
carlsen
uh played right because after h3 i mean
the king on h2
you it's not very i mean it's also fine
right so i mean everything's fine
here for white but the kingdom g2 looks
so nice
yeah and also h4 can follow in some
positions as happen in the game in the
future
so let's say yeah bishop e7 out g3
d3 magnus carson is playing step by step
and this is one
calcium-esque position right tight
position he's going step by step there's
no risks
he's got a tiny advantage but enough to
put pressure until tomorrow
and this is something i really like
about magnus carson because like let's
say like
20 years ago there was or maybe 15 years
ago
there was a tank where the the the
players didn't fight so much in top
tournaments right
and they were criticized a lot like
there were so many trolls
without fighting in like 10 15 moves
maybe more years ago i don't know 20 30
years ago
but with these new players they fight
till the end for example magnus cause he
doesn't
agree for a draw you know he has 0.01
he'll try till tomorrow
and that's why i admire magnus cousins
so much not only because of his play
style which i also love but
also because of his attitude in the
chess board
he's always going for the win he's very
competitive
and yeah he's the number one in the
world
okay so g3 quincy eight from arie and
toddy and here
magnus carlsen goes for queen d1
maybe he's thinking about transferring
the queen let's say to f3 or even h5 in
the future
but also he frees the a file for the
rook
this rook can come to a7 a6 depending on
the situation
a7 just putting pressure on the seventh
rank a6 putting pressure on the d6 pump
which is going to be a weakness
all the time and uh
yeah aryan's winning today i also
when we were we were doing the the pause
like between one lecture and another one
i just checked the games
for norway chess and magnus carlsen is
just making a dry relief against uh
firouza so they'll play armageddon it's
gonna be quite exciting
and uh what else yeah aryan terry has a
nice position so i'm very happy for him
because he's suffering a lot in this
tournament i think he's got one drone
seven losses
which is very very painful for john
player 26
something uh rated and
i would love him to play some to win
some games yet
to finish at least with some positive
results yeah in this
today's game and tomorrow's game
and okay so uh in many
cases you can also transfer this knight
to e3
this is always something that ariane has
to take in account too so
white has so many options that this is
just a nightmare for black
right you can you have to pay attention
to the rook to the
on the a5 with a knight transfer to e3
and then d5 and f5
ideas with h4 h5 also with f4 at some
point
but actually opening up the position
with f4
i don't think it's a great idea not yet
because this could give some
uh hopes for this bishop on e7 right
okay so g6 from aryan 30 he doesn't want
to have troubles on the background
and magnus carlsen goes kng too step by
step
you know he's using his biking cream
he's just doing a massage on his
opponent you know now arie and todd is
just
laying down on a bed you know magnus is
using his cream
and bishop f8 from aryan chari
well black cannot do much in this
position b2 is
well controlled from the knight on c4 d5
is
hard to achieve and uh yeah what else
can you do with the black pieces in this
position well just wait and then hope
for the best
so magnus carson continues with queen f3
and rook b3 from aryan chatty putting
pressure on c3
so magnus wanted to keep this rook on
the a file so
what would you play here with white you
will bring this rook to c1 or this rook
to c1 the a-rook or the a-rook
yeah i like your plan mitran h4h5 this
is always
a nice idea and then try to open the age
file
and then put some pressure right there
the e file the e-rook right yeah i also
think that magnus did the right thing
because this rook on a1 is extremely
active and the rook on e1 is
doing nothing right and you have no
prospects of
opening this e file so that's why i
believe this is just
the best thing to do and the rook on a
on a1 is very very active
and threatening to jump into
[Music]
the enemy's territory to create some
troubles
my lunch break oh aryan good luck you
gotta go
lunch break is about to end okay so have
a nice
working day i don't know where you are
but have a nice working day
don't work too much queen e6 from marion
charlie
and now rook a7 finally the rook
comes into the seventh rank school
awesome so rook 87
and now adi and toddy plays rook b7
and magnus trade one pair of rooks rook
b7
rook b7 and now let's think
so how do we proceed here with the white
pieces
so now this rook on c1 is doing nothing
this is a hint for you guys
this is a hint for you guys so the druk
is doing nothing we should always think
about
improving the position of our pieces
yeah rook c1 to a1 right this is very
clear
very nice and now again this rook coming
to a8 will
create some troubles on the background
let's take the a file right luis and now
eight
five from mr ali antari and rook
a8 from
magnus carlsen
sorry a sec
and yeah
i am combining school with this that's
cool
what are you studying aryan i studied
civil engineering i
i started in 2005 i'm too old man
2005 i finished 2010 i studied in
granada
my hometown and
uh but later i i did my masters in italy
germany and poland that was an a nice
experience
um i that was the first time i
was living out of my house it was a nice
masters because we were like 45 people
and we were from 25 different countries
in italy so it was such a nice
experience you know i was
sharing the flat where the first month
was seven italians because i wanted to
learn the language
and then i was sharing the flat with two
nepalese
and one indian and uh wow
i i had i have so many great memories
from that time you know so
[Laughter]
so cultural shocks yeah because i first
arrived to to the room
and then i went to the toilet you know
and then when i finished doing the thing
you know
i i wanted to take the toilet paper you
know and there was no toilet paper you
know so
i was asking my friends where's the
toilet paper no we don't use toilet
paper
so my friends ready anand
and mahesh
nice memories
okay so rk8 and kg7
from marion tariq
move knight a5 to move the black rook
well yeah for example if knight a5
i guess now well now black has an
interesting option for example
queen a2 queen a2 just spinning this
knight after knight b7
queen a8 and the knight is dropped so be
careful with these moves
yeah and even though black has to move
the rook let's say rook c7
you didn't achieve anything right
because now this knight is completely
misplaced
on the a5 square and probably has to go
back to c4 there's nothing
uh great for this knight on the a5
square so this is a very simple thread
just to take the
just to capture the rook but the knight
is not improved
on these squares that's why i wouldn't
go knight a5 in this position
carlson finally transfers the knight
what would you do here with white
because everything looks so cool right
we got all our pieces active but then
he decides to go knight e3 in this
position
and then he's gonna install the knight
on d5 and then
f6 could be a weak square
so rook c7 from arianetari and
knight d5 rook c8 now my question
is would you take on c8
would you avoid the trading of rooks and
where would you go with a
a8 rook in that case
so would you take on c8
rook a7 that's great i'll no see because
i mean you have an active rook and then
black has a passive rook
we are targeting f7 this rook is
basically doing nothing
it's just in front of this guy on c5
carlito spawn
so roo k7 that's right the rook is still
active
and i couldn't believe that in this
position black cannot move black cannot
do
anything i mean you can never move the
bishop
you can bring even if you want you can
bring the rook to b2
it's not gonna do any single thing and
now i want you to
focus and i want you to give me
one interesting plan for y to improve
the position because black
incredibly has no plan in this position
black has to wait group b a
rook c8 rook d8 but then we have to do
something else to improve our position
with white we got all our heavy pieces
in the past squares the knight on the e5
the rook and a7 the rook on
the queen on f3 but we need to create
another weakness
to win the game
uh you wanted to trade queens here rook
sorry because of queen f6
yeah but the problem with queen f6 is
just black ghost king g8 and then
there's nothing
d6 is protected um black is going with
uh queen e6 and i believe this is just
completely equal so you got to be
careful and rook 87 was the best move
mithran you are extremely strong today
everyone agrees with me transplant or
you have a different plan
do you have a different plan here
my class started adi and he said just
send regards to your teacher
you can say to him you know teacher i'm
just watching pepe
stream for the singles chess club
and probably he'll understand
yeah this is a very very strong plan
from magnus carson i was so impressed
with these games
with this game because this game is not
one of those games where you sacrifice
everything
like some tactics on h7 and then
it's a fantastic finish no this is a
game where you are torturing
your opponent because it cannot move
anything
and adding arientari didn't have a
single chance during the whole game
and magnus was increasing the pressure
from time to time
what about c4 for black that's a
possibility
yeah after rook a7 c4 you can just take
and then again you don't have any
targets everything is well protected
and you can continue with the same plan
h3 g4
so c4 doesn't improve anything
but of course also something to consider
but i guess just take c4 root takes c4
and then
i mean c3 is protected e4 is protected
the rook is doing nothing on c4
yeah but i also like your idea torias c4
would be an option
in this position i mean black went d8
and now c4 is an option
but i think it's not needed because uh
c4 is not a threat from blacks
from black's perspective that's right
juan de leon what about
opening the h uh file you are more than
right this is what magnus carlsen did
and he went for h3 and
sorry rook b8 he went rook b8 and h3 and
you cannot do
anything with the black pieces you want
to dream and come to the
rank and say hey i'm here but basically
this rook is doing nothing on the
seventh rank you have no targets
you have no targets so that's why aryan
tarin
didn't even think about this and he just
kept the rook on the 8th on the back
rank
and now magnus finally
goes for g4 so what to play now
with black do you want to take on g4 you
want to allow y to take on h5
just give me a more for black what's the
idea behind h3 and g4
well to open the position to attack the
skin
and now if black goes well you tell me
what black does in this position
i know it's not easy you have in front
of you magnus carson the world champion
h4 h4 looks to be like the most natural
move
but i believe that if the g5 the
position is still very tough let's say
black
keeps doing nothing let's say c4
let's say rook d8 and now
you can even i don't know how do we
proceed in this position even this
end games are very very hard for black
to play because now
after taking on g4 you're going to grab
this guy on h4 and this is gonna be just
a pawn up
for for
for white but also you have all the
plants like queen e2
queen b2 f4 and
very half a black to play so h4 doesn't
work
but probably is the best right here
and the other reasonable option is just
to take on g4 there are no more because
we are just taking on h5 so
black has to take on g4 or play h4
ariane took on g4 and here i hope nobody
says
that we want to take with the queen no
taking with the queen still we are
much better in this position but i think
it's just
very good to take with the pawn because
now what is our plan
what is our plan with the white pieces
let's say you can move
two times
so imagine is white stern what's your
move
yeah yeah insane stuff great
man g5 that's a move and then the plan
is to go just
queen g3 queen h4
and then h6 is a nice outpost for the
queen
also the f6 square combined with a queen
on h7 will be just checkmate
and then the bishop can never come to e7
e7 is well protected so this is just
you know so much pressure on black's
position it's like magnus carson taking
a screwdriver
you know and you know tickling you on
the whole body
just desperation mode for black here
and i'm gonna uh answer your question
torias can black sacrifice h5 and key in
the position close
close with g5 for example let's say rook
b8
and now g takes and g5 definitely this
is an option
but for example here you can use a
deviation theme
h6 black should protect the f7 pawn
so after queen takes just rook f7 and
you go king g6
yes go h7 and this is gonna end pretty
bad for black
so keep the close with g5
so h6 h takes and uh
rook d7 from arientari against the again
desperation mode
as i was telling you guys if you do
nothing just g5
rook c8 queen g3 rook b8 queen h4
followed by knight f6 and queen h7
and black can resign so that's why you
aren't aryan terry
he played rook d7 and
yeah mithran again solving the issue
rook a8 again
avoiding the trading of rooks because
this rook is extremely
active and now our plan is the same we
want to continue with g5 queen g3 and h4
so that's why
aryan plays f6 bringing fakundo to the
action
and aiming to stop that plan question
for you guys
how to proceed with the white pieces
let's see if you find magnus carlsen's
move
knight b6 yeah these ideas that bringing
the knight to
the queen side doesn't help at all rook
b7 and you're gonna go back to d5
so no no knight v6 this doesn't improve
our position at all
yeah g5 open the position up
blow everything on the key inside g5
and black can't take on g5 because the
bishop on f8 is just hanging
so black should close the position with
f5
and now
give me the move give me the move
black is trying to close with f4 so you
cannot
bring this queen to the key inside
because
h6 now is a very important square
come on guys just two more moves and
then we're done
queen h3 woof so painful
so painful this move because now
black can't move this pawn because the
queen is
hanging and also we are threatening just
check mate in two moves with queen h6
and arientari was trying to defend this
position and he went for rook f7
covering the f eight square uh its
square bishop
and this is the moment where magnus
carlsen
finishes the game with a fantastic blow
let's see if you guys find magnus
solution probably you see another ways
to continue the game which
which are completely fine
so why to play and finish the game
any ideas
yes very very nice
very very nice probably you're thinking
about this move queen h6
or knight f6 all very reasonable queen
h6
king g8 knight f6 but here after rook f6
pawn takes and queen takes looks like
black can try to hold this position
still this is an advantage for white but
it's not an immediate win
but rookie is just killing a killing
move rookie is just so fantastic you
know
and it's so nice to finish a game with a
tactical blow with a tactical shot
after you have been putting pressure
since 30 moves ago
ready just a fantastic move from magnus
carlsen
what's the point of
rook e8 well black is forced to take on
e8
and now queen h6 check
king g8 queen g6
and black cannot do anything if you move
rook g7 there's queen e8
just winning the queen if you go bishop
g7
there is knight f6 check with a fork you
cannot take with the bishop because it's
illegal
you cannot take it with the rook because
of queen e8
that's why after queen g6 arientari
went for kin8h8 and now you guys tell me
the last move
before we leave
last move just finish your opponent
yeah that's right knight to f6
and black has to resign even though he
is a rook
why because rook f6 is just not possible
and if you move the queen let's say to
c6 or b5
or a4 there is checkmate on
g8 so
what do you think about this game for me
i mean it was just an amazing game was
just
pressure step by step improving the
pieces
once you have achieved the position with
a good knight versus a bad bishop
i put the knight on c4 i exchange a pair
of rooks
i put a rook on a7 putting pressure
the queen on f3 and then the knight on
c4 i transferred the knight on d5
and basically black cannot move in that
position and then
this fantastic plant with a3 and g4
creating a second witness uh just
finished the game with this plan of g5
queen g3 queen h5
fantastic game from magnus carlsen in
this norwegians tournament
stunning game he crashed arientari
and uh super tournament that's still
going on
as you guys know you can still follow
today's
commentary in different websites uh
magnus carlsen facing
firoza and tomorrow will be the last
game and for sure
we'll cover those games uh in the next
in the next weeks in this lectures i'm
always open to suggestions guys if you
want to
see something special in this lectures
just uh tell me in the comments you know
i will always read
the comments uh after uh this video
there's the comment section where you
can
suggest me things to do yeah you wanna
solve puzzles or
you wanna check uh games from kappa
blanca trojan or magnus skeleton
i'm always open to suggestions i'm very
happy to hear about
all of them so it's been a pleasure to
show uh to be here with all of you
just i wish you have a nice evening
wherever you are and just be happy
and stay healthy and see you in the next
lecture here in the saint louis clef
take care guys